now last Sunday saw protests in London
by right-wing activists on a so-called
day of freedom but one person's presence
gained more attention than any other
drag queen vanity von Glo who is here
good morning
nice to see you it has caused a lot of
controversy hasn't it because it was
attended by some sort of very far
right-wing people
why did you attend on what why were you
asked to attend um
I'm not certain why I was asked but I
felt like anyone from the center of the
left has as much entitlement to express
themselves freely as the people on the
right and I think there's an argument
that the right has managed to sort of
co-opt freedom of speech a little bit
lately so what I wanted to do is go and
express myself the way I always do a
dress like this singing songs and what I
wasn't there to do was to expose my own
political views or in any way to endorse
anybody else's well the the problem with
this I guess is that it may have been
sort of tagged freedom of speech but it
was oh is being seen as in effect a
right-wing rally
now a right-wing in some cases who
perhaps racist perhaps homophobic and
not the sort of people you would
normally be mixing with no not just sort
of people I'd normally be mixing with
you know to be clear I'm not a fan of
hate speech if that's if that's people's
concern about but the language used on
the right and on the far right I've been
on the receiving end of hate speech all
week so I can tell you it's it's not
nice but you know I mean for example did
the former leader if the BNP is called
Mia I've written it down because I keep
forgetting of the sickening us I'm a
sickening gender confusion I think the
head of the alt-right in America has
called me a degenerate so you know
needless to say I don't endorse the the
far-right views being espoused well look
I've got to say I have some sympathies
with you because if you're getting that
from the far-right and it's a dreadful
language but you're also getting a lot
of stick now from the left because just
because you were there oh my goodness I
mean they're really in some ways they're
just as bad I mean I would I would thank
the left because they do seem to have a
slightly more expansive vocabulary than
the
the fire rate so they're not just
calling me a degenerate they're also
calling me a fascist for having
associated with myself with this event I
mean I feel a little bit like if you
stand still for more than five minutes
at the moment the left go that far in
that direction that we're all far right
the problem is that the far left you
don't just go for calling you names
they're a sort of party chick at the
moment is to try and go for your source
of income you know at the moment they've
been making sure that that my my shows
are canceled they want to see me
unemployed possibly they want to see me
homeless and that's quite an aggressive
tactic simply for disagreeing with my
Mo's for attending an event yeah so what
are you gonna do now how'd you tackle
this I mean do you try and gee I was
gonna say did you try to keep your head
down and let it drift apart but you're
not doing that well on the one hand it's
important you know it's important for me
to continue to express myself in exactly
the way I'm doing now you know this
guilt by association thing is difficult
for me to handle because I've worked
very hard in my life to you know to
promote fairness for everybody what's
especially difficult is that the venues
that I'm associated with some of which
are independent venues they're social
medias no become a proxy war between the
far left and the far right all fighting
over this this which which I don't think
is fair I don't want people to do that I
don't want these venues to be affected
while they're trying to take some
breathing space so I guess what I've got
to do is listen listen to people's
concerns have conversations about this
and hopefully I'll be ready to get back
on stage very soon